Muai Thai ist ein Nationalsport in Thailand.
Schon Elfjährige stehen sich - wie hier im
Nordosten des Landes -
im Boxring gegenüber und kämpfen um Ruhm und Preisgelder.
Umgerechnet etwa 38 Euro kriegen diese Jungs
pro Kampf, bei einem Sieg noch einmal um die
77 Euro als Siegprämie dazu.
Für viele Familien in Thailand ein willkommenes
Extra.
Die jungen Boxer hoffen auf eine Profikarriere
- und damit auf eine Chance ihre Familien
aus der Armut zu holen.
Und das hat in den letzten Jahren immer mehr
junge Thaiboxer angezogen.
Fachleute sehen diesen Trend zunehmend kritisch.
Die Gesundheit der Kinder stehe auf dem Spiel
sagen Ärzte wie die Neurologin Jiraporn Laothamatas.
In einer von ihr durchgeführten Studie hat
sie Hirnschäden und Gedächtnisschwächen
bei jungen Boxern nachgewiesen.
"Es gibt kein "sicheres" Boxen.
Man kann es bei den erwachsenen Boxern sehen.
Sie kriegen Parkinson, verursacht durch die
Hirnschäden beim Boxen.
Bei den Kindern drohen die Unterentwicklung
des Gehirns und andere Schäden.
Das ist wirkt sich wesentlich schwerer aus."
Die Expertin fordert ein Verbot der Vollkontaktkämpfe
für Kinder unter elf Jahren.
Davon sind Eltern und Trainer wenig begeistert.
Sie sagen, der Sport vermittle den Kindern
Disziplin und halte sie von der Straße fern.
Außerdem glauben viele, Schläge und Tritte
der Kinder hätten noch nicht genug Kraft,
um Schäden anzurichten - trotz der Warnungen
der Fachleute.